Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Ça fait 25 ans que je travaille en forêt.
Chaque fois que je sors de la ville
et que je vais dans les forêts,
j’explore toujours cette frontière entre
ce monde civilisé et ce monde sauvage,
la fameuse frontière que tant d’écrivains
et tant d’artistes ont aussi explorée,
entre nature et civilisation.
Chaque fois, je suis un peu consterné
que ce soit si binaire.
C’est-à-dire que
ce monde urbain, hors-sol,
soit en complète opposition avec
ce monde sauvage, ce monde naturel
où la forêt se développe.
Il se trouve que la forêt
a plein de vertus,
ce qu’on appelle la multifonctionnalité.
C’est-à-dire que non seulement elle
est belle, elle revêt tous nos paysages -
c’est magnifique ! -
elle participe à l’écosystème,
elle nous permet de respirer,
elle participe au cycle de l’eau.
En plus, elle produit du bois, ce matériau
renouvelable qui est aussi durable,
et qui peut se substituer
à tout un tas d’autres matériaux.
Donc c’est formidable la forêt.
Il y a un an, j’ai été sollicité
sur un site industriel
d’une grande entreprise
d’expédition de courrier et de colis.
On m’a dit : « On est plein
de bonne volonté, on est sincère,
on a envie de bien faire,
on a envie de participer à cette
grande transition environnementale.
Qu’est-ce qu’on peut faire ? »
J’ai proposé quelque chose
d’un peu alternatif,
un paysagisme standard, conventionnel.
J'ai proposé d'implanter une forêt.
Fort de l’ingénierie
que je pratique au quotidien,
j’ai proposé effectivement de copier ce
que la nature aurait fait spontanément.
C’est effectivement une démarche
intellectuelle qui dicte mes actes.
Ça vient d’un grand ingénieur français
au début du XIXᵉ siècle,
1824 peut-être, qui a condensé
toute cette pensée en disant :
« Imitez la nature, hâtez son œuvre. »
C’est vraiment le travail du forestier :
identifier et comprendre
comment la nature agit, où elle va,
et l’accompagner dans cette dynamique
pour essayer d’accélérer cette conquête
de l’espace par la forêt, par la nature.
Je me suis servi de ces leviers.
On a fait une analyse fine du sol
qui s'appelle la pédologie.
On a fait une analyse du climat,
on a étudié le site, l’altitude,
le relief, la géologie.
En fonction de ça,
on a défini les conditions nécessaires
pour l’implantation de cette forêt,
quelles étaient les essences, les espèces
végétales qui allaient pouvoir s’installer
si on laissait quelques siècles s’écouler.
On appelle ça l’autécologie des essences,
c’est-à-dire qu’on a analysé
pour chaque espèce
quelles étaient les meilleures conditions
pour qu’elle puisse se développer.
A cet endroit-là, on a mis des chênes,
des charmes, des pins sylvestres.
On a mis une trentaine d’essences
différentes, d’espèces différentes,
pour reconstituer
ce qui serait une forêt naturelle,
avec un curseur de temps qui se serait
allongé indéfiniment si on avait le temps.
Sauf qu’à l’ère de l’anthropocène,
le temps, on commence à en manquer.
On s'en rend compte.
Tout le travail a été d’accompagner
la nature dans cette dynamique
pour accélérer, ne pas attendre
qu’un oiseau vienne avec la bonne graine,
la mettre au bon endroit, que le vent
souffle les bonnes espèces au bon endroit.
On a accompagné la nature.
Pour moi, cette transition,
elle est intéressante
parce que j’ai appliqué mes méthodes,
ma technique, mon ingénierie, en ville.
Je suis forestier et j'ai travaillé
sur un site industriel.
C’était assez antinomique
et en fait, c’est plein de sens.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu’en fait,
ça vient s’inscrire
dans des petites actions
qui vont s’additionner.
C’est-à-dire que demain,
j’imagine que plein d’entreprises
vont faire ce genre d’efforts,
parce que c’est un effort,
mais qui sera récompensé.
Parce que tous les îlots que vont composer
ces différentes petites forêts
vont composer à leur tour des collectifs
qui vont être des corridors,
qui vont participer à cette transition
environnementale des entreprises.
Ce qui m’anime aujourd’hui, c’est qu’il
n’y a pas eu que cette petite forêt.
Ça a aussi été l’occasion de pédagogie,
de prise de conscience de la part des
agents travaillant dans cette entreprise
et qui, tous les matins, vont passer
devant cette petite forêt.
C’est un petit rappel quotidien
des grandes forêts qui poussent
un petit peu plus loin.
On n’en est plus au stade de la prise
de conscience, vous l’avez compris.
Il ne faut plus avoir peur.
Ce n’est pas parce qu’on n’est pas sûr
que le projet soit parfait.
On n'est pas sûr que ça marche.
Il y a un pari,
il y a un risque à prendre.
En fait, tant qu’on n’est pas
passé à l’action, on ne sait pas.
Et donc c’est : « Action, maintenant ! »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)